ドラゴンボール！みんな知ってるかい？
ベジータがブルマに
もっと強くなりたいから
からっつって
重力がかかる部屋
を作ってもらって
そこでこうなんかトレーニングしてた
覚えがあるんすよ
いつもより重力のかかる場所
体を動かす事によって
筋肉が倍増すると
僕は考えたわけなんすよ
僕の体重は今65キロぐらいなんで
僕の体重ぐらいのおもりを
体じゅうにまんべんなく
つけることによって
僕は重力のかかった世界に
いるような感覚に陥ることができる
そうすることによって日常的な
動きをするだけでもう
僕の体には大きな負荷がかかる
その分筋力がつくので
いっきにトレーニングになるということを
僕は考えたわけなんですよ
というわけで今回
手首足首につけるおもり
があるんですけども
それをほとんど僕の体重と
同じぐらいの重さの分買いました
体じゅうに全部つけて
日常的にこうトレーニングするわけっすよ
そうすることによって
ドラゴンボールでいうベジータとかさぁ
悟空みたいにね
地球ではありえない重力が
僕の体にかかるわけなんですよ
今のこのおもりを体じゅうにつけて
２倍の体重だ
筋力を増大させようと思います
であの～
危ないです
ヘタすると一発で
ぎっくり腰になるので
ちょと仲間をつれてきてるんで
みなさん絶対にまねしないように
まじでぇ！
ケガするぜぇ
ではいきましょう！
腕だけとだと
こっからうってつけるだけでいい
あ～イタッ
☆TI☆N☆KO☆
オォイもう
はいというわけで一応全部出しました
これが約体重分あるということなんでぇ！
これを体じゅうにつけていきます
おぉ～！おうほう
これは、やはや
やはややはや
あーチ◯コ
（もう力いれてないじゃんもう）
いれちゃ、いれちゃダメなんだって
全部ついた瞬間にいれたい
これがか！みたいな
これが！これが！
地球の重力の２倍か！
ってなりたいな
ああーお！
あ”あ～イタッあ～お！
ああ！イェイ！イェイ！イェイ！カモンカモンカモンカモン
あもおおぅ！
オーマイガッオーマイガッオーマイガッ
おっけおっけ!
あ～オーマイガッ　オーマイガッ・・
おうおうおう・・
（アーユーレディ？）イェイ！！
あ”～オーマイガッオーマイガッおっとぅ
オーマイマイマイオーマイ
オーマイノコッタ◯＃△
％＄’＆？＊
マダガスカル。
オーマイ（アハッハッハ）
あ”ーオーマイゴッテス
ねえ！乳首　メッポ
（あげて、あげて、ンポ）
あ”～！乳首すれた
♪
いきます！いきますよ！
っんあ
やっやば
まって、ちょとまてまって
くぁっ
はぁっ
まってすごいＧがかかるこれ
やばいっ
これが、地球の２倍の
体重の重さか！
あ”～
うぉ～
うわっおし！
あっいける！
うぉ～～！ァ～ァイ！
あっイッタまったく刺さる
まってクソダサいじゃねーかよこれｗ
いつもの地球の２倍の重力を
感じておりますが
割とね！動きますよ
んぁっ
あ”っ！
くぁ！
これで腕立てとかするんでしょ？
いきます！
い”い～いや～
♪